so is it true that you still send Oprah
to thank you letters like a year I do
you know Oprah and I met in the late 90s
yeah uh when she was in trial and I was
on the trial team and uh then you know I
started doing the show and then started
doing the show a lot and then we
launched the show and
uh
you know it really changed my life a lot
uh I had a great life when I met her and
I've got a great life now but she
changed a lot of things and it's just
been really important to me
every year to stop sit down and write
her a letter
and say thank you for the impact you've
had on me and my family and I I've done
it every year for 25 or 26 years and she
told me something one time the first
time I launched a book on her show
I sent her like a huge flower
arrangement and a thank you note stuff I
think she'd been on the air 17 years at
that point and she called me and said
you know about all the things I've done
all the books and stuff so this is the
first time anybody's ever said thank you
what first time anybody's ever said
thank you oh wow and I I thought wow
that's hard to believe yeah
and now I've had my show for 20 years I
understand what she means oh man I
understand what she means and so I don't
know I just I've got this I've got this
value don't forget who brung you to the
dance yeah and I've never let her think
I forgot who brung me to the dance yeah
I love that
[Music]